- We got to talk about The Voice.
- Oh yeah
- This is Kelly's show.
Now you an advisor on the show,
but you were working against Kelly.
Is that true?
Boo.
- That is a fact.
- Oo
- I feel like I need to take
a shower now thanks a lot.
Ariana Grande I've known
since she was 10 years old and
she called and asked if I would,
if I would be her advisor and
we had been stayed very close
and I said, but besides Kelly's team,
I think Ariana's team is very good.
- Oh wow. Wow wow there you go.
There you go.
Now did you guys,
you and Arianna used
to go on double dates?
Is that true?
- We had some. Well, not to,
you know, not as a couple,
which there's nothing
wrong with that, but no,
with the other partners.
Yeah, we had some dates.
Yeah.
- But not when she was 10.
- No.
Then I'd be in jail.
- Well that's right, exactly.
- And we just go and we like bowling,
we like truffle pizza
from Craig's here in LA.
Have you had truffle pizza?
- What kind of pizza?
- The truffle pizza at Craig's.
- Okay. All right there. Okay. No
- Have you had it?
- I haven't. In my family
I'd be beaten if I had a truffle pizza.
- You know what.
- It's like pineapple on a pizza.
- I agree but no, I'm,
you're wrong on this.
Just will you trust me.
Will you trust me Jay?
- The cheap Italian food is the best town.
Once you put truffles
on it and some pig going
(Jay pig snorting)
on my pizza. Ya know.
No, it doesn't no.
- It's yums.
- All right.
- Your missing out.